Kita percaya komputer kuantum akan memungkinkan kita menyelesaikan beberapa masalah lebih cepat dari yang bisa kita lakukan dengan komputer klasik saja. Tapi
memahami caranya itu rumit. Hari ini di Qiskit in the classroom, kita akan mencoba mengungkap sumber kekuatan
quantum computing dengan melihat salah satu algoritma yang paling awal.
Selamat datang di Qiskit in the classroom. Dalam seri ini, kita akan menggunakan Qiskit untuk menjelajahi beberapa konsep fundamental
yang umumnya dibahas dalam kursus terkait quantum computing. Setiap video disertai modul interaktif
yang ditautkan di deskripsi di bawah. Jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu. Kalau kamu banyak mendengar tentang komputer kuantum, kamu mungkin
sudah dengar bahwa mereka bisa menggunakan fenomena kuantum seperti superposisi, entanglement, dan interferensi untuk menyelesaikan
masalah dengan cara yang tidak bisa dilakukan komputer klasik. Tapi bagaimana tepatnya fitur-fitur ini membantu? Pada tahun 1985, David Deutsch adalah orang
pertama yang menunjukkan bagaimana ini bisa terjadi. Dia menciptakan apa yang sekarang disebut algoritma Deutsch yang bisa menyelesaikan
masalah lebih efisien dari algoritma klasik. Hari ini, kita akan melihat algoritma Deutsch dan
ekstensi selanjutnya yang disebut algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa dan memeriksa bagaimana aspek qubit yang unik secara kuantum
bisa digunakan untuk keuntungan komputer kuantum. Kemudian kita akan menjalankan algoritma-algoritma ini pada komputer kuantum nyata dengan Qiskit.
Ada algoritma kuantum lain di luar sana yang juga menunjukkan keuntungan teoritis atas algoritma klasik yang diketahui. Dan tidak semuanya bekerja
dengan prinsip yang sama seperti yang akan kita lihat hari ini. Jadi apa yang akan kita pelajari hari ini tidak menjelaskan secara umum bagaimana
komputer kuantum bekerja, tapi ini membantu kita mulai melihat bagaimana prinsip-prinsip mekanika kuantum bisa digabungkan untuk
membuat komputer kuantum yang kuat. Sebelum menyelami algoritma Deutsch, mari kita pikirkan dulu bagaimana komputer kuantum
berbeda dari komputer klasik dan bagaimana itu mungkin memberi kita keuntungan dalam menyelesaikan masalah
tertentu. Satu perbedaan adalah bit kuantum yang disebut qubit bisa berada dalam state superposisi. Daripada dibatasi
pada state nol atau state satu seperti bit klasik, sebuah qubit
bisa berada dalam state superposisi dari keduanya, nol dan satu. Kita menulis state ini seperti
ini di mana a dan b adalah bilangan kompleks yang kuadratnya berjumlah satu dan semakin banyak
qubit semakin besar celah ini meluas. Dua bit masih hanya bisa berada dalam salah satu dari
empat state yang mungkin ini. 0 0 0 1 1 0 atau 1
1. Dua qubit bisa berada dalam superposisi dari semua empat state yang diizinkan secara klasik itu yang
ditulis seperti ini. Secara umum, sistem klasik dari n bit hanya bisa berada dalam satu saja dari 2 pangkat n kemungkinan
kombinasi nol dan satu. Sistem kuantum dari n qubit bisa berada dalam superposisi dari semua 2 pangkat n dari state-state
ini. Skalanya eksponensial. Jadi bahkan kalau kita hanya punya 10 qubit, mereka
bisa berada dalam state superposisi dari 2 pangkat 10, yaitu 1.024 kemungkinan kombinasi nol dan
satu. Skala eksponensial dari ruang state qubit disebut
paralelisme kuantum dan sebagian bertanggung jawab atas keunggulan komputer kuantum atas komputer klasik. Tapi komputer kuantum
bukan hanya prosesor paralel masif. Hanya karena qubit dalam komputer kuantum bisa berada dalam
superposisi dari banyak state secara eksponensial tidak berarti kita memiliki akses ke semua informasi dalam masing-masing state
ini. Karena pengukuran meruntuhkan sistem ke satu state atau lainnya, mari
kita lihat bagaimana ini bermain dalam masalah yang sederhana. Katakanlah ada semacam mesin yang
bisa kamu masukkan satu bit ke dalamnya. Kemudian mesin itu akan menerapkan beberapa fungsi pada bit dan mengeluarkan satu bit lain. Mesinnya
berada di dalam kotak hitam yang tidak bisa kita akses. Yang bisa kita akses hanyalah bit
yang kita masukkan x dan bit yang dikeluarkan kotak f
dari x. Kita ingin mengetahui apa fungsi f yang diterapkan mesin itu.
Ada empat fungsi yang mungkin yang mengambil satu bit ke satu bit lainnya.
Jadi untuk mengetahui apa fungsinya, kita bisa memasukkan nol dan melihat apakah ia mengeluarkan nol atau satu. lalu masukkan
satu dan lakukan hal yang sama. Masing-masing dari dua langkah ini disebut query. Ini
adalah salah satu cara membandingkan algoritma klasik dan kuantum melalui apa yang disebut model query di mana kita membandingkan jumlah
query yang perlu dilakukan masing-masing algoritma pada kotak hitam untuk menyelesaikan masalah. Jadi dalam kasus ini, metode klasik kita
perlu melakukan query dua kali ke kotak untuk mempelajari fungsinya. Mari kita lihat apakah kita bisa berbuat lebih baik kalau kita punya
komputer kuantum yang melakukan query pada kotak hitam. Daripada pertama memasukkan nol lalu satu,
komputer kuantum bisa memasukkan qubit yang berada dalam superposisi nol dan
satu ke kotak. Jadi efektifnya, kita memasukkan kedua input dengan satu query. Lalu
apakah itu berarti kita bisa mempelajari fungsinya hanya dengan satu query?
Sayangnya, bukan itu kasusnya. Kita lihat kenapa ide ini gagal ketika kita mengujinya pada komputer kuantum. Kita akan membuat
circuit dengan dua qubit. qubit nol yang direpresentasikan di sini oleh garis atas ini akan menjadi input state X yang kita masukkan ke
kotak hitam yang ditunjukkan di sini oleh gate berwarna merah marun berlabel UF. Gate UF
dirancang untuk mengambil qubit nol sebagai input state X lalu menerapkan transformasi pada qubit satu yang mengambil
state nol ke state f dari x. Jadi selama qubit 1 dimulai dalam state
nol maka outputnya adalah x pada qubit 0 dan f dari x pada qubit 1. Jadi untuk menemukan f dari x untuk
x=0 dan x=1 secara bersamaan kita bisa mencoba menempatkan qubit 0 dalam superposisi 0 dan 1 sebelum
kita masukkan ke kotak hitam. Itu dilakukan dengan Hadamard gate merah ini yang mengubah state nol menjadi 1 / akar 2
kali 0 + 1. Jadi setelah gate kotak hitam, kita seharusnya sekarang memiliki superposisi dari keduanya
f dari 0 dan f dari 1 pada qubit 1. Ketika kita mengukur dua qubit, kita berharap untuk
menjawab pertanyaan, fungsi apa yang ada di dalam kotak hitam. Mari kita gunakan Qiskit primitive sampler untuk menjalankan
circuit dan mengembalikan hasilnya. Kita bisa memilih jumlah kali circuit dijalankan yang disebut sampel dengan mengubah
parameter yang disebut shots ini.
WEBVTT
Ini setara dengan jumlah query yang kita lakukan pada kotak hitam. Mari kita lihat apakah hanya satu query akan
berhasil. Ini hasilnya. Kita mengukur qubit 0 menjadi nol. Jadi itu adalah
nilai input x dan qubit 1 menjadi 1, yang merupakan nilai output f dari x. Jadi sekarang kita
tahu f dari 0 sama dengan 1. Tapi bagaimana dengan f dari 1? Di sinilah masalahnya. Setelah
kita mengukur state tersebut, superposisi runtuh dan kita hanya bisa mengukur satu bagian dari fungsi dengan
satu query. Ini tidak memberi tahu kita semua yang perlu kita ketahui untuk menentukan fungsi apa itu. Kita akan membutuhkan
query kedua dari kotak untuk itu. Jadi meskipun prinsip paralelisme kuantum memungkinkan kita secara bersamaan
memiliki kotak hitam mengevaluasi f dari 0 dan f dari 1, kita tidak memiliki akses ke keduanya
jawaban itu. Paralelisme kuantum saja tidak cukup. Algoritma Deutsch
menunjukkan bagaimana kita bisa menggunakan paralelisme kuantum dengan cara yang sedikit berbeda untuk belajar tentang fungsi di dalam kotak hitam. Kita tidak akan
bisa mengetahui persis apa fungsinya, tapi kita akan bisa belajar sesuatu yang baru tentangnya dengan
satu query yang tidak bisa kita lakukan dengan komputer klasik. Mari kita mulai dengan melihat tabel empat fungsi yang mungkin
yang mengambil satu bit ke satu bit lainnya. Di sini kamu bisa melihat bahwa dua fungsi f_sub_1 dan f_sub_4 selalu
mengembalikan satu nilai terlepas dari state input. Kita menyebut dua fungsi ini
konstan. f_sub_2 dan f_sub_3 akan mengembalikan nol atau satu tergantung pada
state dari x. Kita menyebut dua fungsi ini seimbang. Algoritma Deutsch
menentukan apakah fungsi itu konstan atau seimbang dengan membuat beberapa penyesuaian cerdas pada circuit yang kita gunakan
sebelumnya. Ini circuit-nya. Dimulai dengan menyiapkan qubit 0 dalam state 1 / akar
2 kali 0 + 1 dengan Hadamard seperti sebelumnya dan qubit 1 dalam state 1 / akar 2 kali 0 minus 1
dengan NOT gate diikuti Hadamard.
Jadi state penuh pada titik ini adalah di mana ini adalah state dari qubit 0 dan
ini adalah state dari qubit 1. Menyiapkan qubit satu dengan cara seperti itu daripada hanya
membiarkannya dalam state nol memungkinkan algoritma menggunakan paralelisme kuantum dikombinasikan dengan interferensi untuk belajar
tentang fungsi kotak hitam. Mari kita lihat bagaimana ketika qubit dimasukkan ke UF gate kotak hitam beberapa hal bisa
terjadi. Kalau fungsinya konstan, maka kotak hitam akan melakukan beberapa operasi pada qubit satu saja terlepas
dari state nol. Dalam kasus ini, karena UF tidak menyentuh qubit nol atau
peduli dengan statenya sama sekali, maka Hadamard kedua di sini hanya membatalkan apa yang
dilakukan Hadamard pertama. Dan kita akan mengukur qubit berada dalam state nol. Mari kita lihat fungsi seimbang f_sub_2 sebagai contoh untuk melihat
apa yang dilakukan UF pada state dalam kasus ini. Ketika x adalah nol, f dari x adalah nol dan ketika x
adalah 1, f dari x adalah 1. Ingat apa yang aku katakan tentang gate UF. Ini mengambil qubit 0
sebagai input state x kita dan mengeluarkan f dari x pada qubit 1. Dengan asumsi bahwa qubit 1
dimulai dalam state nol. Jadi untuk fungsi ini apa yang dilakukan UF pada qubit 1 bergantung
pada qubit 0. Kalau 0 adalah nol maka qubit 1 akan dibiarkan dalam state nol untuk mendapatkan f
dari x = 0. Kalau qubit 0 adalah 1, kotak hitam akan menerapkan NOT gate pada qubit 1 dan menempatkannya
dalam state satu. Jadi kita mendapatkan f dari 1 sama dengan 1. Ini persis yang dilakukan gate controlled NOT atau CNOT. Sebuah
CNOT gate mengambil dua qubit, qubit kontrol dan qubit target, dan membalik
state dari qubit target jika qubit kontrol berada dalam state satu. Tapi tidak melakukan apa pun pada target jika qubit kontrol
berada dalam state nol. Jadi UF untuk F2 hanyalah CNOT pada Q0 dan Q1. Gate CNOT
tidak akan melakukan apa pun pada suku pertama karena qubit kontrol berada dalam state nol. Tapi pada suku kedua, nol ini
terbalik menjadi satu dan satu ini terbalik menjadi nol. Dan kalau kita memfaktorkan tanda minus, kita akan melihat bahwa state qubit 1
tidak berubah. Tapi suku ini sudah mendapat tanda minus. Jadi state qubit 0
sebenarnya yang berubah. Ia berubah dari 0 + 1 menjadi 0 minus
1. Ketika kita menerapkan Hadamard terakhir pada qubit 0, ini mengubahnya ke state 1. Jadi kalau fungsi dalam kotak hitam
adalah f_sub_2, kita akan mengukur satu bukan nol. Ternyata gate UF untuk fungsi seimbang lainnya f3 adalah
gate CNOT yang sama diikuti NOT pada qubit 1. NOT gate terakhir itu tidak mempengaruhi qubit nol. Jadi ketika fungsinya
seimbang, kita akan mengukur qubit 0 berada dalam state satu di akhir circuit. Sekarang kalau kamu tidak mengikuti semua
ini, tidak apa-apa. Aku menyarankan kamu untuk menjalaninya sendiri untuk melihat bagaimana cara kerjanya. Poin utama di sini adalah apa yang
terjadi ketika kita menerapkan CNOT untuk dua fungsi seimbang. qubit 0 hanya digunakan sebagai qubit kontrol untuk mengubah
state qubit 1. Secara intuitif, kamu mungkin berpikir bahwa qubit 0 akan tetap tidak berubah. Namun, entah bagaimana
operasi kita pada qubit satu sebenarnya mengubah state qubit nol dengan mengubah fase relatif antara dua bagian
dari superposisinya. Fenomena ini dikenal sebagai mekanisme phase kickback dan ini
sangat kontra-intuitif seperti banyak fenomena kuantum. Dengan cara tertentu, kamu bisa berpikir tentang mekanisme phase kickback
seperti mendayung perahu. Tindakan mendorong air ke belakang sebenarnya mendorong kamu ke depan. Sama seperti operasi pada
qubit 1 yang sebenarnya mengubah qubit nol. Sekarang kita bisa menjalankan algoritma Deutsch di
Qiskit. Di sini kita bisa memilih fungsi mana yang dimasukkan ke dalam kotak hitam yang kita pilih sebagai F3. Ini adalah
diagram circuit dari algoritma dan kita bisa menjalankannya seperti sebelumnya dengan sampler primitive. Kita akan mengatur jumlah
sampel menjadi hanya satu dan melihat apa yang kita ukur. Dalam kasus ini, kita mengukur satu.
Jadi, kita tahu bahwa fungsinya seimbang, yang memang sesuai dengan harapan kita karena kotak hitam mengandung fungsi f3. Jadi, hanya dengan satu
query, kita bisa membedakan antara dua kelas fungsi ini.
Ini akan membutuhkan algoritma klasik dua query untuk menentukan. Ini menunjukkan keunggulan sederhana dari
quantum computing atas komputasi klasik saja, tapi tidak terlalu mengesankan. Hanya satu versus dua. Tapi algoritma Deutsch
WEBVTT
masih sangat penting bagi sejarah quantum computing karena memberikan percikan yang membuat orang lain
berpikir tentang algoritma kuantum yang lebih besar dan lebih canggih.
Ini termasuk ekstensi multi-qubit dari algoritma Deutsch yang mendemonstrasikan keunggulan kuantum yang jauh lebih mengesankan.
Ini disebut algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa. Ini menyelesaikan masalah serupa, tapi dalam kasus ini, fungsi kotak hitam
yang ingin kita pelajari mengambil n bit sebagai input dan mengeluarkan satu bit. Seperti
sebelumnya, kita dijanjikan bahwa fungsinya entah konstan, artinya bit output selalu satu atau selalu nol,
terlepas dari string bit input, atau seimbang, artinya outputnya nol untuk
setengah dari string bit input dan satu untuk setengah lainnya. Tentu saja ada fungsi-fungsi lain
yang mengambil n bit ke satu bit yang bukan konstan maupun seimbang. Tapi dalam masalah ini, kita
dijanjikan bahwa tidak ada fungsi-fungsi itu di dalam kotak hitam. Yang ada di dalam kotak dijamin entah konstan
atau seimbang. Circuit Deutsch-Jozsa terlihat mirip dengan algoritma Deutsch, tapi dengan lebih banyak qubit. Di sini kita punya
implementasi algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa untuk mempelajari fungsi tiga bit. Kali ini kita punya tiga qubit
untuk state input daripada hanya satu. Dan kemudian kita punya qubit terakhir ini untuk state output. Seperti sebelumnya, lagi
kita menyiapkan semua qubit input untuk berada dalam state 0 + satu dan qubit output
untuk berada dalam state 0 minus satu. Kemudian meskipun matematikanya sedikit lebih rumit untuk diikuti, prinsipnya
tetap sama. Kalau fungsinya konstan, ia tidak akan bergantung pada tiga qubit teratas sama sekali. Jadi state mereka
akan berubah kembali ke nol setelah Hadamard kedua dan pengukuran kita akan menghasilkan string tiga bit semua
nol. Tapi kalau fungsinya seimbang maka ketika kita mengukur qubit setelah Hadamard mekanisme phase kickback
akan menyebabkan satu atau lebih dari bit-bit itu menjadi satu. Itu mungkin tidak mudah dilihat kali ini tapi kalau kamu mengerjakan
setiap langkahnya sendiri kamu akan segera melihat ini pasti kasusnya. Salah satu cara untuk memeriksa ini adalah dengan mencoba menghitung
probabilitas mengukur semua nol dengan fungsi seimbang. Kamu harusnya mendapatkan probabilitas nol. Mari kita jalankan
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa pada komputer kuantum dengan Qiskit. Langkah yang paling sulit mungkin adalah membuat fungsi Deutsch-Jozsa.
Itu akan menjadi kotak hitam kita yang kita query di sini. Kode ini menghasilkan fungsi Deutsch-Jozsa acak yang
dijamin entah seimbang atau konstan. Kemudian kita membuat circuit Deutsch-Jozsa kita dengan menyisipkan fungsi kotak hitam kita
di sini. Lagi, kita menjalankan circuit dengan sampler dan setelah kita mengukur, kita melihat
bit yang diukur untuk menentukan apakah fungsinya seimbang atau konstan.
Kalau semuanya nol, itu konstan. Tapi kalau ada setidaknya satu bit satu dalam string, maka itu seimbang. Dalam
kasus ini, kita mendapat string bit 1 satu satu.
Jadi, kita tahu bahwa fungsinya seimbang. Semoga aku sudah memberimu sekilas pertama tentang bagaimana algoritma kuantum
bisa memanfaatkan fenomena kuantum yang menarik dan seringkali halus untuk mendapatkan keunggulan mereka atas algoritma
klasik. Kamu mungkin juga sudah menyadari betapa sulitnya merancang algoritma kuantum. Bahkan yang paling pertama pun
membutuhkan banyak kreativitas untuk mencapai hanya kemenangan sederhana atas metode klasik. Dan sejak algoritma pertama itu,
fisikawan dan ilmuwan komputer terus menemukan cara-cara yang luar biasa inventif untuk menggunakan mekanika kuantum
untuk keuntungan mereka, termasuk ekstensi dan aplikasi lebih lanjut dari algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa. Kalau kamu ingin
mempelajari beberapa di antaranya, serta mencoba algoritma Deutsch dan Deutsch-Jozsa sendiri, kunjungi
modul yang ditautkan di deskripsi untuk memulai. Terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali.